[Musique]
bonjour à tous Aujourd'hui je vais vous
parler du film la haine à réaliser par
Mathieu Kassovitz en 1995 avec comme
acteur principal Vincent casselmaoui ou
encore
uber kunday alors ce film s'inspire de
l'affaire macomé MBO aller et raconte
l'histoire de trois jeunes de cités dans
laquelle il y a un grave incident
puisqu'à un jeune a été grèvement blessé
par un policier le film a été présenté
au Festival de Cannes en 1995 et a reçu
le prix de la mise en scène alors moi
personnellement ce que je trouve
intéressant dans ce film c'est que
Mathieu Kassovitz a fait des choix de
mise en scène très intéressant notamment
le fait de mettre le film en noir et
blanc le réalisateur c'est limité à
quatre prises par scène
et ce qui est intéressant c'est que
comme on dans les Yvelines le film a été
tourné en pour la plupart à
Chanteloup-les-Vignes dans les Yvelines
[Musique]
tu me parles pas comme ça ok je te
connais pas
[Applaudissements]
dans le film c'est la scène du
vernissage vers la fin du film parce que
Mathieu Kassovitz voulait que les jeunes
de banlieue soit un peu moins
sympathiques donc il a créé cette scène
il voulait à tout prix aussi dans une
interview je l'ai entendu il voulait pas
qu'il y ait de scène d'amour dans ce
film pour se rapprocher un peu plus de
ce qui se passe dans les banlieues donc
voilà je vous conseille vraiment d'aller
voir ce film c'est très intéressant et
puis c'est toujours d'actualité
[Musique]